Et bien bonjour, comment allez-vous chers amis ? Moi ça va plutôt bien.
J'adore coller le micro à ma bouche. Je pense que vous, vous adorez moins par contre.
Les amis, hier, au moment où je tourne cette vidéo, c'était le réveillon.
Qui dit réveillon dit : cadeaux, nourriture, chansons paillardes de beaufs...
ouais, moi il y en a vraiment un qui en a lancé une.
Mais bien plus rare et incroyable que ça les amis, mon père m'a donné un véritable trésor,
quelque chose d'une valeur inestimable, le plus beau des cadeaux.
Une pochette rempli des dessins que j'ai faits quand j'avais entre 5 et 8 ans !
ah ah C'est le plus beau cadeau que j'pouvais avoir !
Déjà c'est cool car vu qu'il fallait que je tourne aujourd’hui et j'avais pas d'idées
Et ensuite, je trouve ça génial, parce que je me souviens de rien du tout !
Donc ça va me revenir en les regardant. J'ai lutté pour *ʀᴏᴛ* pas regarder. Excusez-moi, c'est les huîtres.
Pour pas regarder les dessins qu'il y a dedans, parce que mon frère a reçu la même pochette mais avec des dessins à lui
et ils les a tous regardés devant moi.
Donc j'avais trop envie d'ouvrir la mienne mais je me suis retenu !
Mec, c'est un véritable trésor qui se trouve à l'intérieur. Quand je vais l'ouvrir, ça va probablement être...
Wouah ! Nan je déconne, en fait dans la pochette, il y avait une pochette. Voilà.
"Dessins Lucas" mec, c'est incroyable !
On va les mater ensemble un par un, je les ai pas scannés donc j'vais devoir vous les montrer comme ça mais bon...
c'est une petite vidéo tranquille, ambiance pépouze à l'arrache après Noël.
Le premier, ah oui, j'adorais scotcher des feuilles pour faire des dessins comme là par exemple.
Oh là là là là, il est grand celui-là !
Oh là là il est grand !
Bah, je trouve ça pas dégueu.
Je vois juste pas trop où est le dragon et encore moins la mort.
Par contre, je vois bien où est la faute d'orthographe, ça y a pas de problèmes.
En tout cas c'est un très beau dragon de la mort. N'hésitez pas à m'envoyer vos dragons de la mort à vous.
J'accepterai que ceux où il y a une faute d'orthographe à "mort" bien sûr.
Dessin suivant.
Juin 99 ! Mec, j'avais 3 ans ! Ça date de juin 99 !
Et c'est stylé ! Il est génial ce perso !
On dirait un mec blasé !
Lucas, "Mon Papa".
Je suis désolé papa.
Je vois pas trop où t'es réellement.
En tout cas, ce que je peux te dire c'est que tu as un gros pénis.
Parce que ça c'est vraiment un pénis, on va pas s'mentir.
Donc j'ai dû te voir une fois nu quand j'étais petit et ça m'a impressionné.
On peut voir qu'à l'époque, je dessinais les pieds comme maintenant, ça, ça m'fait plaisir.
Et à l'intérieur, il y a quoi ?
Oh ! Un poème !
« Dans tes bras, mon papa, je me sens bien plus grand, moins peureux, plus heureux. Je t'adore plus encore... »
J'ai très mal lu ce poème.
Alors ça c'est quoi ? C'est pas du tout un dessin.
Papa, ce que tu as acheté récemment, ça m'intéresse pas de ouf.
Je sais que t'as voulu le glisser dans le dossier en scred mais je...
En tout cas, j'espère que tu auras du plaisir avec ton contrôleur domotique Jeedom Smart Z-Wave, papa, vraiment.
Alors, oh, c'est mignon regarde, une petite lettre pour papa !
Ah c'est mon frère qui l'a fait. Ah mais il s'est trompé de dossier !
Qu'est-ce qu'il avait écrit mon frère ? Oh c'est sa lettre de noël ! C'est mignon !
« Coucou Papa ! Je t'envoie ce que je t'avais dit que je voudrais pour Noël. Bisous. Smack. »
Il voulait quoi pour noël, attention...
Une voiture télécommandée !
« Un robot rapide et capable de saisir des objets grâce à ses pinces puissantes ! Le succès de ta mission est garantie ! »
Alors, si je peux me permettre, je crois que ça a foiré, Florent, car je ne t'ai jamais vu avec ce robot.
Donc, je crois que le Père Noël n'est pas passé cette année-là !
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Ah, ça c'est des trucs que tu devais faire, j'crois à la maternelle ou à la crèche. Tu avais des éléments, tu pouvais coller.
Ah non, fallait juste coller des éléments là où c'était indiqué. D'accord donc il n'y a aucun esprit de création là-dedans. C'est juste euh... Ça sert à rien.
Juin 2001, j'avais 5 ans.
Je comprends rien, je ne sais vraiment ce qui passe dans notre tête quand on est enfant.
Peut-être c'est comme ça?
Comme ça ?
Comme ça...?
J'sais pas c'que c'est.
Est-ce quelqu'un voit le dragon de la mort là-dessus ?
Il est pas là !
Bonne fête papa !
Et mon père, c'est le meilleur des papas quand même.
Il a gardé tout ce que je lui ai offert, c'est ouf nan ?
Ok, il avait reçu une lettre à l'époque avec un truc Disney dessus.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Oh là là, regardez comme je dessinais déjà très très mal.
Je crois que c'est un skateur ou un mec en snowboard.
Ce dessin est nul à chier !
Papa, je suis vraiment désolé de t'avoir envoyé des personnages de cette qualité.
Parce que c'est vraiment pas très beau quoi.
Au dos, il y a quoi ? Pff, Te-ma mon frère comment il dessinait, regarde la diff' déjà.
Il dessinait déjà trop bien le petit bâtard !
C'est tellement... J'avais pas compris à l'époque que faire un dessin de cette qualité au dos d'un dessin de cette qualité,
c'était parfaitement humiliant et ça me mettait pas du tout en valeur.
En fait, je crois que j'ai voulu refaire le perso de mon frère qui était là. La version originale...
La version du putain de pauvre !
C'est génial, ma mère a précisé, elle a mis « Lucas »...
mais c'est tellement évident que c'est moi qui ai fait lui et que c'est mon frère qui a fait le dessin trop stylé au dos.
Suivant !
C'est un certificat disant que j'ai exploré une fourmilière à la cité des enfants.
En 2003...
Bah je m'en souviens pas quoi...
Oh là là là là là, alors là, mec.
C'est Noël. Regarde un peu ce que j'avais fait à Noël.
Un putain de sapin.... en papier qui brille !
C'est bizarre parce que tu sais, t'as des espèces de flash de très lointains souvenirs qui reviennent quand tu vois des trucs aussi vieux.
C'est moi qui l'ai fait donc mon cerveau il a foutu cette info quelque part !
Dans le néant par exemple. Et ca me revient un peu quoi.
Et je me souviens je n'arrivais pas à faire un vrai sapin.
Vous voyez, ça fait pas du tout un sapin quoi. Ça marche pas du tout.
Et j'étais triste parce que je l'avais raté. Mais bon....
Et ma mère, comme d'hab qui précise au dos que c'est moi. Mais maman !
Tu crois vraiment que Florent il va faire ça ! C'est incroyable !
Eh attend, ça s'ouvre ! Oh là là là là, mec,
c'est quali ou pas ? C'est vraiment le standard de l'enfant.
L'enfant vraiment écrit comme ça et fait des trucs comme ça.
Joyeux Noël, maman et papa.
Si vous voulez je vous achèterai un truc bidule chouette
En tout cas, le principal, c'est que vous soyez contents et qu'on ne fera plus de bêtises, Florent et moi.
SI vous voulez, nous chanterons les "Frère Jacques".
Ha ha c'est drôle !
Pour se faire pardonner ils veulent juste chanter
Bisous, à bientôt, Lucas.
C'est mignon. C'est quand même mignon, hein ? Ces petits enfants, ils sont mignons.
Mec, c'est impressionnant aussi à quel point j'écris pareil.
J'ai gardé la même écriture.
Ceux à qui j'ai dédicacé un "Tourne la page", regardez l'écriture c'est exactement la même.
C'est incroyable !
Premier dessin ! Et il est pas dégueu, mec !
C'est quali de ouf, mec ! C'est un perso de Dragon Ball Z.
Franchement, aujourd'hui, si je devais le refaire, je le ferais moins bien.
Mais pour de vrai, regarde j'ai fait du détails sur les muscles !
Je crois que la douille c'est que je prenais modèle sur les dessins de mon frère pour faire mes propres dessins.
Donc en fait, c'était vraiment, juste, je recopiais ce que je voyais. Donc du coup, c'est un peu, c'est facile.
Regardez ça date de juillet 2003, mec. C'est vraiment vieux !
Oh attention un nouveau méchant, après le Dragon de la More j'vous présente
le Démon de la Mort !
Il fait pas peur du tout ! Il a un pissenlit sur la tête mon gars.
Oh ! Et là y a un croquis du Dragon de la More.
Une première version du Dragon de la More, que j'avais tentée.
Un nouveau méchant encore une fois, toujours avec des gouttes de sang
qui coulent des armes c'est très important comme détail.
Oh des barres, les yeux j'les fait toujours pareil.
J'ai vraiment pas évolué !
Oh ! Celui-là il est travaillé de ouf mec. Vraiment là, on s'est craqués.
Mec.
Oh c'est dégueulasse, ça me fait des frissons cette merde.
Bon bah là on est complètement partis en couilles hein
mais j'crois que c'est un Super Saiyan puisqu'il y a une aura de Super Saiyan autour.
Quand je regardais DBZ je voyais ça en fait.
J'avais pas la même vision que les autres.
Attention première évolution :
C'était un tournant de ma carrière
Après ça on m'avait contacté en masse pour m'exposer mais j'avais refusé parce que j'étais trop jeune
Etant mineur je pouvais pas encaisser l'argent donc ça m'intéressait pas.
On crée maintenant de l'épaisseur au niveau des bras. Par contre au niveau des jambes on est toujours sur de simples traits.
Mais franchement, au niveau des bras, qui ressemblent à bites
y a un effort
2001, "Farandole autour d'un feu de bois"
Alors, je pense que le terme "farandole" c'est vraiment ma mère qui l'a écrit
Voilà à quoi ça ressemble une farandole autour d'un feu de bois
On dirait plutôt un rite vaudou de gens qui veulent invoquer un démon
Mais bon !
Je faisais même des espèces de livres avec des petits dessins dedans, nuls
et moches
Comment ça se fait que j'ai arrêté ?
Je crois que j'imitais juste mon frère mais que moi j'étais pas fait pour ça
Oh là là, une oeuvre d'art !
Putain mec j'avais pris ma vengeance sur le sapin de l'année d'avant
J'avais enfin réussi à faire la forme tant espérée de sapin
Bon j'avais juste suivi les instructions de la prof à l'école mais bon
Hé ok ? J'avais réussi à faire ce putain de sapin mec, j'étais content !
Putain mec, regarde j'ai un truc y a encore marqué "La Mort"
C'est vraiment l'expression des enfants quoi
"Hé j'ai fait un ninja de la mort"
Merde je l'ai pété, je l'ai pété papa je suis désolé
Ah mais non il est en plusieurs parties
Ah ok je vais devoir le poser mec
On est en mode Stranger Things
Ok c'est bon j'ai réussi
On a donc un dessin en six feuilles, ça représente une merveilleuse "Racaille de la Mort"
T'en penses quoi ?
Ah il se casse, nan mais c'est dingue ça
En bas on a des tombes, c'est extrêmement glauque
Ceci représente de la neige
Et ceci le logo Nike, de manière méprisée
Et je marche sur un cadavre
Mais pour montrer que c'est un cadavre j'ai juste mis une tête de mort
Bon celle-là a l'air un peu conne, mais moi j'aimais bien
Les plus téméraires reconnaîtront l'inspiration très claire de Poivre Blanc
Les T-shirts Racailles, comme je les appelais avec mon frère. On achetait que ces T-shirts là et on redessinait les persos qu'il y avait dessus
Hé j'étais un thug moi
Et là, on a une pochette vide on vient de tout regarder mec
Putain j'aurais aimé qu'il y en ait plus
Les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
C'était plutôt court
J'aurais aimé qu'on s'amuse plus mais malheureusement il n'y a plus de dessins
On a fait tout ça quand même, il y en a beaucoup
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu
J'adore la nostalgie, les trucs qui datent de 2000, 2002, quand j'avais six ans, huit ans
C'est génial puisque c'est une période que t'as complètement oublié
T'as oublié tout ce que tu as fait à cette époque
Et du coup en retombant sur des trucs aussi vieux tu as des petites fractions de souvenirs qui refont surface comme ça
C'est très marrant
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous plu, et surtout si vous avez aimé mes dessins de quand j'avais six ans
Ça fera plaisir au moi d'il y a quinze ans
Je vous fais un maximum de bisous, j'espère que les fêtes étaient bonnes même si c'était il y a une semaine
Et que vous profitez bien de vos cadeaux.
A très vite !